foreign
foreign
foreign
oh
thank you
foreign
foreign
it is a rainy gross day today
here it kind of looks like how it is on
screen
looks just like that actually
get a couple more fights in how we all
doing dude
how we all doing today baby
hot humid rain's worse
I don't know man it's like 20 degrees
here pouring rain
somehow it's not snowing I don't really
know how that works it's probably not 20
degrees it's probably like 35. it's cold
it's cold man
so cold
what up Dino how are you
let me get Elder ring launched up here
foreign
there you go
I was pretty close 35.
what up mama
foreign
Joy is wet because she just went pee I
need to get her an umbrella
but she's good she's good
she's a good girl and yes she is
she is on the chair in the background in
just a second hold up peeps
it's one degree there oh my god oh
Celsius
damn
you love the cold
I don't
I don't like it at all
I'd rather be warm than cold
so I'm eating my breakfast
so I got my coffee
we're gonna see how far we can get today
baby
75 degrees in Florida the only problem
is that you're in Florida
you know what I mean
laughs
you're in caled my guy
I dropped my controller
thank you Mira
I will go get those two sacred tears in
lorenia I remembered
I wouldn't have remembered if he didn't
say anything we'll see where John Vigor
is he was taking the thumbnail last time
I saw him taking the thumbnail photo
there he is
couldn't be bothered to put his clothes
on
crazy
so am I fat rolling with this oh yeah
oh yeah
good there bada bing bada boom
you look like a typical Canadian hockey
player I do have the
hockey look going on right now don't I
I really do well let's go to lorenia so
that Miro will stop telling me to go get
these sacred tears man I don't even know
where they are
do I
go here
try and remember
good morning thank you good morning good
morning
you like the room this is my living room
dining room area without a dining room
and my setups in the dining room instead
the background is going to be totally
different tomorrow guys
if the movers can move today I hope they
can because it's pouring rain
would be a big ass couch back there
it'll be good
all right
that's right frenzied Flame
isn't that over here
oh man I haven't gone up this way at all
let's just run up this way
might as well hit those
while we uh get ready for the day but
hope everyone's having a great
Wednesday what day is it today
yeah it's somewhere out there
the rain wasn't the worst part what was
the worst part
chilling at work I hate working at a
mall
I don't know I've never worked at a mall
but I thought I think it would be fun
kinda I don't know it probably sucks
I got no opinion
been watching the Rune roulette video
again absolutely hilarious have you guys
seen the insane uptick in that video
go look at my uh Community tab
or go follow me on Twitter I put it on
there too bro
and I put it on Discord I put it
everywhere because it's like it's weird
it was getting like no views and then
all of a sudden the last two days it's
just gone like
what the [ __ ] why does that happen
yeah but it was like
it was at like 8 000 views two days ago
Trey and now it's at 33k I'm like what
the
it's weird
I even had people on Tick Tock where I
posted that clip
I've had a bunch of comments that said
hey I just watched this video on YouTube
I'm like huh
but why does YouTube take two weeks to
push it man I don't understand
I have a hundred thousand subscribers
and I don't know how this platform works
I have no idea
I don't think a lot of people do
I won the YouTube roulette two weeks
later
what up brief
yo
viral marketing
I mean I feel like I did all that
and it had 8 000 views for two weeks and
I'm like damn I guess I can't do
Challenger I'm just and now I'm
rethinking that
I don't even consider myself I I don't
even consider myself the lore guy
would you guys even consider me the lore
guy I would say that's either body or
smoke or probably both
I'm killing her
I feel like it
it's really rainy and cold here right
now
David
that mist
interesting
foreign
I consider myself a theorist
not the lore guy
I will say
as as lackluster as the tibia Mariners
are
their boss design like the way they look
is super
creative I like it a lot
I like it a lot
we got like 12 inches of snow in here
bruh my God
we had snow a few weeks ago but nothing
since
irresistible thumbnails what do you guys
think in irresistible thumbnail is
like go go look at my roon roulette
video
I thought I think that thumbnail is a
banger
I think it looks cool
I think a lot of my thumbnails are
bangers
new couches coming later today
I want to finish my breakfast sorry
just a cliff bar
the serpent Hunter you don't have any
requirements for Ellie but I think
everything scales with something
um
I think your charm as a content creator
fits for challenge runs I have no idea I
can't really figure it out what y'all
like me for
hmm
how long does it take to make your
thumbnails I'd say like 30 minutes to an
hour
probably 30 45
these are all falling apart
they're done
yeah
I do not consider myself the lore guy at
all
never have
I think it's more
um
cinematic
theorizing
which I don't think is lore
because none of my videos I'm like hey
here's this thing and here's exactly
what it means and let me read all the
item descriptions for you
I don't do that
I tell you what the underlying message
is
or what I think it is not what it is
damn get on I'm not even gonna kill that
guy I just want to do
cinematic theorizing is just yelling
into the void dramatically hey I don't
do that either
literally my favorite video I've ever
made I don't talk in it at all
didn't say a word
not a word
God damn this game is pretty
okay hopefully I'm not missing the
because I'm not gonna lie to you guys I
don't know where these churches are
I don't know how to get to the frenzy
flame Village I think it's this way
I think so
you come across chill as [ __ ] dude a lot
of hate Watchers would tell you
different because I yell at them
on these live streams
hi Irby
what's John vigorette we're more than
halfway across the street screen chat so
that's kind of nuts
79 vigor
a glomide king
no probably not
I don't really even have that many
haters I don't know why I said that
I have some
they do not like me
which
if you're gonna make content on the
internet you're gonna have to accept
that people are just not gonna like you
sometimes
and that's fine
we stopped leveling when we hit 99
that'll be the end of leveling we'll
have to just try and beat the game
a dog
I don't think we can even use anything
from him
so I'm gonna leave
what's up tight
yeah it's going well so far Javen but
we're about to enter the end game
after we beat morgot and it's all gonna
go to hell from from there
you know
it's usually how it goes
usually how that partakes I see the
church
I see it
does that mean I had to go underneath no
it does not
our stat talisman's allowed nothing no
talismans that I can only use talismans
that increase my Vigor and that is it
we should also get that other Crimson
Medallion by the way chat I need to go
down below
did that dude just try to shoot at me
just now
I gotta do it sometimes
I gotta look at the game it's too pretty
I gotta do it sometimes
I'll never get over how pretty this game
is
what up DT
yeah I can use my physic
if it can only I can only use physics
that increase my Vigor though anything
that does not increase my Vigor is not
allowed
I played valorant when it first released
I was The Omen Main
on YouTube on a separate Channel
the channel doesn't exist anymore
because I stopped playing valorant I've
been thinking about playing it again
though just on my own time
but when you play games for a living
pretty rare to want to keep playing
games after you're done streaming you
know what I mean or making a video
I played during the beta my name was
Jake from State Farm and I gave Omen
tips
and then State Farm yelled at me for
having that name so I had to change my
name to AGT Jake
get up there by the way
I have to go back I I think this might
be one of the least explored areas for
me
and I avoid this bear
I ran past it before
to say I can't do it again
wait I remember a glitch was here
[ __ ]
it only works when there's not a bear up
your ass
I remember you could jump in that tree
and get up top
hmm
dude I'd rather fight Melania than a
rune bear and I think most people would
agree with me on that
didn't do good things for my mental
health
usually uh first person shooters kind of
work like that you know
oh
so cool
I think the ultimate Challenge run would
be everything in the game is a rune bear
that's the ultimate run chat
good morning Lord frog quad
it's Joyce still on her chair
she's in that chair I put a blanket on
it and she likes to sit there now
am I making progress to where I should
be going this way right
just sub thank you Aiden
welcome
good to have you what do I hear
I hear a thing
I don't know what you are
this is a somber 2 area
wow
man
the car in Manor looks weird from this
angle
Ronnie's rise
can't get there from below gotta go to
dectus lift
oh I gotta get down there don't I
shoot
do I want to start from the gate over
there
dude look at this game
look at that lighting
I'm still waking up Chet you gotta you
gotta give me a minute
okay I'll go to the gate and go across
I've never fought the Kayla crows are
giant dogs dude very rarely I just don't
[ __ ] with them I'm just like yo you're
good
you do your thing you know what I mean
you do your thing I'll be over here
doing my thing and I ain't [ __ ] with
you that's how that works with me
dinosaur dogs and and giant crows nope
um
that look good
well I'm glad you like them Aiden
I think someone asked if I was going to
turn this challenge into a video
maybe a quick one I don't know I I
guarantee somebody else has done a
bigger challenge in the past I have not
personally seen it but I also don't
really watch that much Elden ring
content myself
so I don't know I'm still thinking about
it
it's a possibility
okay I already went here
so I gotta go up and wrap around yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
oh
do a fist only challenge I'm pretty sure
that's impossible
can you scale with your fists
a quick video be worth 20K
I mean I don't know dude I need to stop
comparing my statistics to when the game
was super popular I think that's silly
to do you know I mean
considering I was averaging like 350 000
this summer
I gotta I gotta lean it back a bit
I got I gotta lean back
where am I right now
I need to play this game more apparently
okay it's just another route over here
got it
have you watched the Eldon lean video I
have it's a good one what the [ __ ]
oh it's just the Sun
thought I was about to be swarmed by a
giant
yeah I gotta go back
when DLC is released
Chad am I weird for saying that I don't
I guess they confirmed DLC I guess they
did
they did
I don't I don't know I've I've watched
their their interview a few times
not the interview but the their game
award announcement
it seemed like they didn't want to
you know
it seemed like they didn't want to do it
okay do I need to go below
or do I go up there
I think I go up there
I don't think DLC is coming soon that
that's the other part I I think they did
they did confirm DLC but I don't think
it's coming soon chat
I don't think it's coming soon
at all
didn't want to release DLC or didn't
want to announce it I don't think they
wanted to release it
I think they're working on Armored Core
okay I found the spot chat we're there
we're here we're doing it
we need to have the frenzied playing be
nice to us
just don't look into its eye
uh
let's hit this real quick
torrid's getting hurt
also I don't know if the Elden ring
Community is super interested in armored
Core six
you might be working on Dark Souls 4.
they have they've confirmed that they're
done with dark souls
like there will be no more Dark Souls
I know buddy
I'm interested in armor core six I think
the overall community of it I don't
think they I don't think they're that
into it
article theory that armor code 6 will be
later at the end of the year and Eleanor
will need a Game of the Year Edition
so theory is March April
for
armored Core
that'd be pretty quick don't you think
okay there's the church finally
I think I gotta fight
Mikey boy here
what is armor core look it up do you
think Elder Ring's a 10 out of 10 yes I
do
I'm the Elden Lord now
[ __ ]
what up Peter we're doing good man how
about you
to go along with the Game of the Year
Edition
okay what would that change like what
what's the point of Game of the Year
Edition
I have the better spear
Spear of the church
do you think All Souls games are 10 out
of 10.
I think sakiro's a 10 out of 10. I think
bloodborne's a 10 out of 10 and I think
Elven Rings a 10 out of 10. I think the
other ones are like nines
in the Dark Souls 2 I don't have an
opinion on neither do I don't have an
opinion on Demon Souls yet either
because I haven't finished it
I don't have an opinion on Dark Souls 2.
Dark Souls 3 is so [ __ ] good chat but
I don't think it's 10 out of 10. I think
it's like a 9 out of 10.
it's not as good as Elden ring
like Eldon ring is like pretty much Dark
Souls 3 but just way bigger and better
to me
there's lots of aspects that are like
amazing about Dark Souls 3.
I love Dark Souls 3.
um bloodborne is like I would say maybe
the perfect game
I might even favor bloodborne
to Eldon ring
to be honest okay where's the other one
where's the other one Chad
the other Church
so I found one
Mira knows where
Dark Souls 2 is a 4 out of 10.
I haven't finished it I will say from
what I've played and I played six hours
of Dark Souls 2 I don't like it
but I think I should finish it
can you check the map yep oh I can um
well I'm in the way
let me let me get my stupid head out of
here there you go
I already got Bellum church is that the
only other one
yeah we talked to Millicent
no we haven't we should go there
yeah yeah well let's go to Millicent
also do you guys like
webcam or no cam
let's do a throwback for about five
minutes here
the streams used to be just me and my
beautiful voice
hmm
listen to me
webcam is great when you make faces Peru
but don't you guys like the silence when
I die
just kidding I'll be back
cam makes it more personal
yeah but what if I don't want to get
personal with y'all
that's a lie of course I do
you're my only friends okay
I prefer when you stare at the camera
when you die
see now you want me to turn it off
okay where else
you know what I'm over it let's go fight
Morgan
if we need more we will go get more
uh I would assume you have never been in
a relationship
what about me made you assume that
James
the [ __ ]
damn bro
I think that's the first thing James has
ever said
and I caught it
caught him
plus m is maximum and current progress
right I need to go to other areas to get
more right
what about that poor girl you're just
gonna leave her there whimpering
what poor girl
who's poor ah I forget about you
oh I wanted her to jump me
hey I just want to know if James was
serious or not bro
I don't think he was
foreign
what made him say that
were we talking about relationships I
guess kinda we're talking about
personal stuff
oh come on
all right let's go easy Farm
he said something that was annoying
hmm Millicent I have no reason to talk
to her because we don't want any we
can't increase our dexterities so
there's no point
we still have one more Talisman slot
chat
I'm definitely not using shabiri's woe
hmm
yeah I have B
yeah where's ER tree's favor
does that only increase my Vigor and
nothing else
charge attack talisman
I think we should get these before
morgot
so the camera's in the wrong spot
I guess so John I've never done a rune
level one so I don't know also endurance
but does it increase the attribute
that's the point
as long as it doesn't increase the
attribute we can use it
by baby Mogan the sewers
oh shoot so I have to kill him first huh
I think you have to kill morgot before
you can even go down there right
because he has the seal
let's just see how we're doing also as
we've said from the beginning we can use
summons that are a part of the fight
like melanin here
I'm gonna watch this and drink my coffee
correct David Grace correct tarnish
hi Astra what is thy business you kill
mode without killing Morgan
oh that's right you can't go down to all
the dead merchants
that's right godric the golden
retrieve flavor plus one isn't there
ever archery favor plus two where MOG is
kind of coffee it's black coffee with um
some creamer but it's not black it's a
Krispy Kreme
Luna princess Ronnie
you think I get bully morgot I don't
know
willful traitors oh
our tree favors in the lake area at the
bottom of the lift after you burn the
tree
you guys are saying all different stuff
right now
just
emboldened by the flame of ambition I
miss when his sword lit on fire
I thought that was cool but I guess it
didn't make sense to the Lord
and if you're a new player you never saw
that but if you played on release his
sword would like light on fire and break
all that stuff and then they changed it
lost of all Kings
that's some good damage guys
that's some really good damage there
it's a weird attack to use right there
foreign
hello y'all seen that before what the
[ __ ]
foreign
he's not staggering
very good
77 in there
got the big hits in
big
but did like nothing
I can't see
get up
no I didn't mean to use that okay it's
good it's good
mama's gonna die
Melina's dead
he's popping off right now
it's going Hog Wild
it's gonna be close
foreign
let's [ __ ] go
easy clap
easy money
w
first try
first try Morgan
I'm not happy with our damage output
the damage is is quite concerning also
He's Just Not staggering
uh maybe that was just kind of weird
because I couldn't hit him consecutively
but man I need to find more ways to use
the charged attack the double charged
attack you know
I said oh isn't there a Charged attack
physic
Ally as well prevented by the mantle the
Thorns
become my purpose
and
a uh
talisman
we should get those and then I should
find more ways to use that charged
attack because we can
we have plenty of Health
you go ahead and like the stream chat we
just one-shotted morgot um kind of
insane kind of good in the membrane
if you haven't liked the stream yet go
ahead and give it a like I'd appreciate
it thanks
um
give it a like
83 vicker
hmm you get that one from the earth tree
avatars I think can't remember which one
I think it's this one
this one
right
I think it's this one
let's go kill it anyway
it's not
Raptors feathers armor you think I
should get that too
ax talisman
we do have one more Talisman slot but
everyone wants to get me everyone wants
me to get her tree's favor
it's in the Mist wood so it's that one
by that archery
oh
over here
I'm gonna go get it
let's go see what they are let's just go
experiment chat
and then if I remember right The
Feathered armor is like somewhere weird
it's like in a cave
Oh you mean the Miss Wood ruins
there's ruins in here besides where
blight is
Mages cave
are those the ruins
we also have not gotten down gone down
there yet
we probably should
spiked cracked tear and green spill
the Talisman is in the room ruined your
blood
I can never see where I'm going in here
it's in a cave at Altus where you get
see what I mean
foreign
's gone
ignore the bear
well there's a smithing Stone too
is it underneath the bear
foreign
you asked for feathered guard to be
honest we've been talking about three
different things so I'm not surprised
why I'm not giving this who I am
confused
ax talisman
is this worth it for us enhances charged
attacks
hell yeah it is
that Bear's weak as [ __ ]
I ain't worried about that bear other
Bears though damn bro
okay
um
we'll have to check those physics as
well I'm curious
I'm curious what this one is
the one I was looking at before you guys
were saying that it wasn't it
Sage's cave by Altus Lake
Sage's cave by Altus Lake
where's the archery Grazing Hill
I don't think I ever hit that one
it's like over here
is it the cave that's like in the Swale
right here
tree plus one's at Mount glamier
you guys you guys notice how calm I am
today I'm trying to be more calm
with chat
because I think I've been a little mean
to chat the last few streams
y'all don't deserve that
some of y'all do most of y'all don't
have you gotten a new game plus seven
I like making new characters I've never
done
I've done a new game like once
mean is good
it's not man I don't want to be mean I'm
nice I'm a nice guy
do I deserve it
I don't know you tell me
foreign
yeah some of y'all are into it
I'm trying to be more calm today
that's my goal
I'm having a nice calm day and you know
why
I'm excited for today chat because a
couch is is probably gonna get in this
house and I'm gonna be so excited
a nice big cozy black leather couch
right behind me
it's all I want
couch w
so is it this cave
[ __ ]
you're not my dad
so it's not there
all right let me just go this way
under Landell where you first fight Moog
so why are some people telling me that
it's in Mount glemmer and other people
are telling me it's somewhere completely
else
completely
not where you said
a different path a different place
honestly I don't go to the shade of
Castle that much this place scares me
because they're wrong
I'm just trying to get to a side of
Grace if we want to come back here then
we can it's
potential later on to increase
our efficiency and mid-max
our playthrough
as the the chat so desperately wants me
to do
from time to time
and there we go there we are look at
that
yeah they barf worms and it's gross
archery favor
yeah they're talking about plus one and
plus two Mike
what should we get
you know what I'm actually gonna tell
you so
here's where I want to go I want to get
the feathers armor where is that it
enhances jump attacks
where's that
that's what we're focused on until we
get it and then we'll talk about the
next thing okay
I feel like a teacher
I dead ass feel like a teacher Sage's
cave
is where the dragon pops goes
Dragon pops out then goes away
Dragon pops out and then goes away
there's a cave over there
really
I don't have the claw Talisman but I
have the ax talisman
land sacks
after magma worm I don't since I'm
already in Altus Plateau I don't have to
go and fight the magma worm correct
I'm already here
I'm up in this [ __ ]
which I'm pretty sure is over here
somewhere
like this way
let's go figure that out chat
I feel weird being this calm
I want to tell you all to shut up
am I going to
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay
have I changed
you want the old Jake back
foreign
well now I'm just not letting any of you
get to me that's the difference here
you literally can't affect me
I've been broken by that sorcery
play through
I broke after that day
I broke
oh it's down to the left [ __ ]
man
Jesus
I get this at least
how have I not grab this and this
okay it's that way I know where I am now
I know where I am I know I am
yo how how many of you guys know about
rocket League Jake
oh my God
I was a different person
I really was
Stan was around for it whoo
you guys did not want that smoke I'll
tell you what right now
you guys did not want that smoke
all right
where where
here
is it just on one of these things
uh oh here he comes
is he gonna [ __ ] with me the entire time
at the lake this ain't a lake
my name is Jake
in the Cena Lake
I got a rake
out by the lake
Chad's got a bad take
I like to eat steak
is it over here
a cave of some kind
okay
hmm
damn I literally couldn't even see that
the [ __ ] was fake
out by the lake 80 miles from Santa Fe
oh if I remember right this place is
crazy right
foreign
going on here
Lantern what do you think
chat
you think I'm gonna get the lantern
I already killed you man
I think I'm gonna get a [ __ ] Lantern
look that's a lantern right there
I like making it harder for myself
okay old Jake's coming out I do have a
torch however
I believe that is fair
torches are cool lanterns are dumb
wow I'm really glad I have this [ __ ]
torch
foreign
yeah I'm kind of nuts at the game
immediately gets hit
stop poking me
excellent
there must be some good loot in here oh
my God
four chests in one spot
a
foot
a black hood ooh
ooh a shield
and a worthless item excellent
excellent
you think my character's feet hurt you
think Jon vigor's feet hurt
running around here Barefoot yo what up
all right
that was rude
why are there so many chests here
stop it
oh you're a big boy
okay yeah you're a big big boy holy [ __ ]
see this is why the lantern would be
helpful isn't it
because I could two-hand without it
right right right right right
there we go
[ __ ] that [ __ ]
wait it gets back up
no
okay
damn
I want you all to know that I'm wearing
socks today as well there will be no
feet
you only catching me like that way
that's some only fan stuff
oh here we go
I don't even know what's in here I have
no idea
hello
it's invisible
why do I not remember this boss
okay
yeah let me just look at the look at the
feet
where is it man
got him
I don't have a mimic chat
this one's aggressive as [ __ ]
okay
this is ridiculous
does it Dodge immediately when I attack
it also sucks that I can't lock on
I hate this
I also can't see
it keeps back ing up dude
foreign
no
dude this is so annoying
no that's not it
foreign
okay
so you're telling me mid jump attack she
can grab me
wow
I don't remember that fight at all
not even a little bit
don't like it
okay I know I don't even have to go like
I don't even have to fight her do I
if I don't have to do it I don't wanna
that's not what we're here for
yeah yeah I got it Chad the Sentry's
torch blah blah blah blah
got it thank you I understand I know how
it works I know where it is
uh not gonna use it because I'm not
gonna fight her probably I might fight
her again though
check your phone
I bet it's a picture of feet
yep
yep
there it is
hey we got it
that's what we were here for
does the mask enhance jump attacks
hello no it just looks sick
nice
the no pants situation is quite odd
manual thanks for becoming a tarnish man
welcome good to have you
thank you very much
I think that's the first member of the
day
why does Jake's stream have to include
feet why not man
you got a problem with feet dog
hmm
is there better stuff in here
oh that's where the boss is
um
oh I am fat rolling
here now I'm not
I'm gonna do this
we're out of here
we're out of here
feet feet
Yes I think feet feet foot
Brent thank you for that man
incredible input
two bosses yeah no thanks don't forget
your Frost pots oh my God
you're right
jaben thank you for the five Brent thank
you for the two
the amazing input all right
thinking
what else can we get
how bad do you guys want me to get er
tree's favor
which I'm
like a thousand percent sure is down
where MOG is
I'm a thousand percent sure now
we could fight Moog
oh we should do more God's Great Rune as
well Rue
tree hugger favor
get some maidens
Ayo facts man
I'm trying all right
I'm trying bro
I'm putting myself out there
you know how it is
shit's hard out here bro
Ash Capital plus two well we might as
well get put do we need it
we got Crimson Amber medallion
Green Turtle Talisman Viridian Amber
Medallion plus one and the ax Talisman
do we need it right now
oh let's check our physics there's too
many things to think about
this was supposed to be so simple guys
where we just level vigored and it's not
these aren't being simple enhances
charge attacks we found it
uh
let's do that too
that's where it was
it is behind Moog and the highest
upgraded Crimson Amber should be in the
sewers on some corpse
so you're saying we should go through
the sewers
is this what you're telling me
think it is
to kill that
yeet
yeah yeah yeah
why do they make
the door is so
it's kind of a lot you know
take a while
so epic
let reichardt swallow you the inside is
so soft and warm
can everyone give me a singular huh
to whatever the [ __ ] Brent just said
just a single huh
huh Crest question mark
huh
it's a little sus
we aren't
you know
I think this stream's pretty sus
press one in chat if you agree this
stream is suss sometimes it's a weird
place
it's a good place to be though
it's fun here
but it can get weird it can get suss
and very odd but we have a good time
I don't know if we need the claw
talisman
I think this just means I'm sus
because that's how streams work right
the chat behaves as the as the streamer
Acts
you know
this is how it would be
anything that happens in the Stream is
my fault
thousand percent
agreed
why did he go to the side like that what
the frick
excellent
chat you all know what we're about to do
right wait should I not do it
because we need a certain item
s
sorry read that wrong Crimson Amber is
here after Malik if Earth tree is still
there though
oh okay
well thank you for the donation I
appreciate it
hold on I didn't have my stuff pulled up
there we go
for the four dollars and twenty cents I
appreciate it thank you that goes to
Joy's treat fund
so thank you very much guys
you grip
might as well do it the skip
um
had to Dono you missed my message my bad
bro
sometimes I miss them
it do happen sometimes
why do you have the snake spear because
it's poggers
that's why you guys think I can do this
again first try
I won't even give you time to answer
because it's gonna happen boom there it
is
I'm a literal God at this video game
it's just absolutely [ __ ] unreal how
good I am
foreign
it is amazing how good of the video game
I am
Pro Gamer you could say okay it wasn't
that
wasn't that all right let's just go down
let's just go down I'm gonna leave that
one to live
I'm gonna leave them up there to cry to
his dead parents and his dead siblings
it's kind of vibe we got going on today
okay that was too far
this is an internet live stream you
control tone and I would pin 90 on you
but some of the weirdness is just random
through however here's what I've learned
sometimes you don't gotta answer to chat
sometimes you got to put them in their
place and sometimes you just leave them
alone
first try again Lord of Suez Jake good
stream thank you Angel I appreciate that
Super Chat
thank you guys
a lot of support today
you know what we're lacking on today
though is the memberships and the likes
probably let me check the likes
118 likes man
yesterday we got 400 likes by the way
which is kind of insane and it was like
a five six hour stream
so
that'd be cool to try and top that today
although Wednesdays are usually the
slowest days on YouTube statistically
so
if it doesn't happen it doesn't happen
you also told us to shut up if you start
saying and asking weird [ __ ]
well
you know we're fine someone tell tight
that he's a little bit uh behind
is not live
I want a 420 light goal
he bonked the roof
nice delay [ __ ]
I love sliding mode
thank you
this music is amazing as well
you're gonna type just want to let you
know you weren't on live
slow and patient
as I get [ __ ] do a jump attack
foreign
there we go
big attack
shouldn't it on the big attack
I think it's physic time
definitely
we want to do the charged attack
the openings are pretty scarce with Moke
however
that could have been a moment
this is a moment watch this 13.
damn
that physic is so worth
oh whatever
don't throw it'd be cringe
the confidence levels
the egos
the egos
oh
[ __ ] I'm gonna die
all right
I wanted to do it to the music drop
John Vigor claims another foe
claims his runes as his own
to enhance his vigor even further Beyond
what do I change it with we have ER
tree's favor plus one what am I
switching out here
Crimson Amber we can yeah man dude this
is gonna be a tough decision actually
Super Saiyan 3.
this is to go even further Beyond
Crimson Medallion yeah I don't think we
really even need that anymore
increases maximum HP stamina and
Equipment load boom there it is
look at us go chat
I will say I feel like I've gotten
actually pretty good against smoke
uh in our times doing these challenge
runs
86 vigor
we're almost maxed out Chad
you can maybe put on some more armor I
think you're right
do I have like better pants I don't
think I do
see no fat rolling
excellent
so that didn't really even help us that
much
did I not have the turtle equipped that
entire time
you need more vigor
um I feel like you're kidding
eat
so you guys wanted to do fia's questline
for this whole thing right
because of her affiliation with vigor
it's a that's kind of a rare one when we
that we don't do that much so I I kind
of agree with that one I think we should
do that
do you guys think that I could be a
voice actor in one of these games
and if I was a voice actor
what kind of character do you think I
would be great
job apps you doing so and you do you
think where I come from
let's get a hug guys
you could get the great jars Arsenal
charm what does that help with
you are favorite song
honestly I think it's four to sacks
his whole OST I think is my favorite in
the game now
yeah we got to do Ronnie's questline as
well
today's kind of a chill day chat because
I'm not sure when I'm gonna get the
phone call that they're coming with the
couch
so we're gonna do all the [ __ ] that
we need to do and get as far as we can
and then we'll try and beat the game
tomorrow
bet I am would you like the blessing
would you like to oh no I don't I don't
want to be held again
all right
a character on gentian impact
why would you say that also none of
y'all said anything about my question
except for that person
voice actor of Bach
someone who has a happy ending
that was it
oh you would be Reichard
hmm
you could voice an onion head guy from
Dark Souls
okay now I know a lot more of how you
guys feel about me
huge stressing
try doing a melancholic voice how do I
do that
what's melancholic
like
you are so like how she's talking
melancholic despite so
I would
okay give me a line to say give me give
me lines
and then I'll act it for you
get pitch me a script
and I'll read it and you can tell me if
I could be in a game or not
it's probably gonna be something weird
okay I'm gonna do Joey's
try finger
butthole
I am Melania blade
of mcquella oh [ __ ] I said it wrong
I'm [ __ ] around these guys aren't
giving me good good reads
I have to say it in a British accent
well with a prowess how would you like
then I'll introduce
Melania is so well balanced she's my
favorite boss if you can say that and
make it believable you'll be a real
actor
hmm how can I do this without being
cringe
I for some reason my instant reaction is
to talk like Roger
Melania is so well balanced she's my
favorite boss in the entire game
and did you know you can use Frost pots
against her and when she does the
waterfowl dance it instantly stops her
inner tracks
that was like Australian or something
that was weird
the [ __ ] was that
I dreamed of Paris again
that came out like weirdly Australian
and I switched up oh no
wait let me listen to him real quick
pleased to meet you wait the name is
Roger pleased to meet you name's Roger
okay I'm done
there's no way it's that bad there's no
way it can't be that bad
where am I going again
what am I doing
we're doing all the weird [ __ ] and and
what was it again I'm literally drawing
a blank now
oh fee is [ __ ] so now we got to go to
yeah okay
I know what to do now
can you do Black Guard America's tits oh
is that what you wanted me to say
America's tits wow
oh bro
your British English sounds like a New
Yorker hey what the [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you [ __ ]
hey [ __ ] you and your mother okay
[ __ ] you
man
I'm weird
let's continue
being a voice actor has got to be so
hard
I feel like I'd cringe a lot
like how do you think the voice actor
felt
in uh for Godfrey when he had to yell
Warrior
I don't know if you felt real good about
that one
potential
oh
dude my [ __ ] froze what the heck
my poop froze oh there we go we're good
hey I'm walking in get the [ __ ] out of
here come on get the [ __ ] out of my way
come on man
see I missed a bunch of this
try godric's Voice
well no
a lowly tarnished nope can't do that one
I'm not old enough for that one my voice
isn't like as raspy as it needs to be
not raspy like
experienced
well
I command thee kneel
nope I'm just not not good enough I'm
not old enough for that I think
I gotta I gotta be at least in my 40s
for that one
try a deathbird screech I have neighbors
not gonna do that when I was at my house
I would flock like a bird
give you a nice Screech
where's my Jojo
he's on the chair right here
looking out the window
hello love
is that okay
hello love weren't you the bloke wait
who beat the living piss out of me
at a me depressed mom
hello love weren't you the bloke that
beat the living piss out of me depressed
mum at that Ron
wait
who beat the living piss out of me
depressed mum
hello love weren't you the bloke that
beat the living piss out of me depressed
mum
that's pretty good that would be a good
take
that wasn't bad
Archie's just hates me I get that vibe
from him
that's fine
no I'm not gonna shout Mike that's
cringe
damn
something
foreign
was that good probably not I don't know
how that voice actor nailed reichardt so
well
maybe the guy in full plate male and
Sakura okay dude
you guys don't believe in me
you just don't and it's understandable
it's understandable
hey if you didn't like my voice Archies
you wouldn't be here I'm just saying
You Gotta Give me good lines or maybe
maybe I should just read them like
myself like maybe if I just sound like
me
it would sound good in game I have no
idea
like if I was just like
pleased to meet you my name's Jake
just like that
pleased to meet you the name's Jake
and uh I think you're an idiot but
welcome to the lands between
now I know being here is kind of cringe
but you're just gonna have to get over
it
if you want to play the game that you
played
[ __ ] I already messed up if you want to
play the game that you paid sixty
dollars for
you're gonna have to get through all
this [ __ ] that you don't want to do
and that's just kind of how the name of
the game works
you can do it and I believe in you
and it sounds too artificial
yeah
I don't think I'm meant for voice acting
sounds sad and it's perfect
I'll get more sad
I'll be the dude in the corner like this
like Millicent in the church just going
oh my God what the [ __ ] and then you'll
come up and talk to me and I'll go if I
have to listen to one more [ __ ]
person in the lands between tell me to
use Frost pots on Melania I'm literally
going to commit scooter ankle
laughs
man
that'd be just funny
I'd have no questline I'd be just some
dude who only says that oh I believe
I have no memory of inconvenient
invitation
no Intrigue intriguing I am the wit that
I might want well
your voice got a lot bassier when you
put your hand up I mean okay
so I think these microphones are meant
to be this close to my face I see
however I don't want this thing right up
in my mouth all the time so I move it
away from my from my face so it doesn't
sound as good as it could when it's
right here
I anticipate but then I put it here and
talk a little bit louder
what sounded better good foreign
I'm not gonna throat the mic
all right it sounds good right here
uh why did I send this back now
yeah I would be a merchant that only
sells raw spots really closer huh
all right we're gonna do uh the rest of
the stream like this Chad
it's gonna be a nice ASMR
Elden ring playthrough Vigor only
challenge
if you're new here make sure to like the
Stream
as it's the only way to grow a live
stream on YouTube to my knowledge
again
together
let us give all together
you could talk in a super deep voice
like Zion
Zio's voice is very unique isn't it
put the mic under your sweater why would
I do that I see yes I I don't know what
since I asked
I asked if it were up to him but does it
really sound better this close
yeah I feel like this
comes out a lot
the f-fizz will be kind of weird
I am not going to put this in my mouth
chat
I will not do it
I know that you're all horny and you
want me
to deep throat my microphone but I'm
gonna go ahead and tell you right now
that I will not do that ah you're gonna
have to get to the only Fan's goal if
you want to see anything like that
now let's go underground
and
[ __ ] a [ __ ] up if you could
all right I'm gonna go back to here I I
feel like it's just too much
about a fist away
Probably sounds
good enough
it sounds better close
um
the Boost is insane I think that's just
me man
I'm hatching a plan on robbing my
neighbors
yeah how much money would uh like
because the goal is 5 000 members if you
guys wanted only fans right we're at
339. 338 I can't really see that
so we need about 4 600 and some odd more
that's a lot of money
yes I got the archery favor
try the balance between quality and
comfortability okay
let me let me get it in a spot and you
guys let me know how this sounds okay so
it's not going to be all all up in my
mouth
but this is closer how does this sound
we sounding good very poger wager smile
potential Giga Chad
what do we think
it only costs twenty three thousand
dollars to gift that many members did
you just say only
better huh
very pogger Walker indeed
stuck on new game plus six Godfrey any
tips dude you've beaten him five six
other times I think you're good
5 000 members Archies
what's your fan base age majority I feel
like there's a lot of kids here and mean
a lot no
uh
my age demographic is like anywhere
between the ages of 18 and like 45.
and then most of them are like in their
20s
bro shits money every day I don't know
man we're at two members out of 50 on
the goal today
I feel like I should lower the goal it's
kind of a lot
50 members a day is kind of uh probably
too much to ask for at this point we
need more we need more viewers to to do
that
bro I'm 11.
nice
I'm 52 39 11 25 32 24. I mean I'm just
telling you guys what YouTube tells me
11 year olds aren't allowed on YouTube I
think they are Trey
twitch's rules you have to be 13.
instead of viewer goal I don't know if
that's a thing we can do
it's also not a thing that we can
control like at all oh I should have
took my clothes off and let's fight my
character
is is this character gonna have as much
Vigor as I do
looks like it
oh they're doing the wrong ashes of War
a battle of the gods
get annihilated kid
imposter
foreign
so a lot of vigor to deal with chat
it's a lot of vigor to deal with
hmm
yes
there's too much bigger
too much Vigor on the battlefield man
there's just too much vigor
I'm gonna have to put a stop to this
GG
what the okay there we go he's so spongy
I think that's kind of the point of the
entire build my guy
use a mimic chat should I
feel like that's not like a part of what
we're doing
and a lot of people get mad about using
mimics
bigger count
86.
so we're almost maxed
well you should or probably shouldn't
that didn't help me at all
bye bye
mimic equals more Vigor does it
two sponges Logan
that's true too
why do they place a deer right here
every time
you're like we got we gotta have
something for them to hit
while they're running through here
I would say to try to avoid it
yeah dude any excuse to avoid the
annoying people on YouTube
because I I think I do want to turn this
into a video
I don't know if it'll be interesting or
not
I feel like if I were to title the video
it would just be like
I don't know
what would the title be
oh
whoa
useless mimic info you can equip the
host of fingers mirror Talisman and
summon your mimic you'll be fully forced
be fully colored as the player that is
completely useless information
I hate you not clickbait
okay do you guys really want me to go
that crazy with the click bait
because I could
I changed the last video to clickbait
and it worked
it literally worked
we went from 8 000 views to like 35 000
in two days over a two-week span
sane
because I changed the title of the video
I think that's so dumb by the way
what up Finn
how are you
I think most Spirits are fine they
sometimes go against the spirit of
challenges yeah I think I'm not gonna
I think I won't
just don't want to make people mad man
I'm not into making people mad unless
they deserve it then [ __ ] them
most broken OP build ever would you guys
say that's what this build is
I don't know if I'd say that
how well do the lore videos do they
don't really do that well anymore man I
don't think there's a lot of interest
unless you're vati or smoke
until DLC comes out of course
these challenge rounds are always fun to
do
I'm gonna do whatever's fun
it's what I've always done and will
always will do
I'm gonna hit this
yeah the end game is gonna suck I can
already tell
vati's a
uh will always be an outlier
really
vati is not someone to compare yourself
to at all
sounds good Finn
hope it goes well
even though he's late
being late matters
can just make a video whenever he wants
I don't have a password
whoopsie
foreign
lots of those videos
requiem
I should make what oh a password
I guess I could
why is he doing it so much
excellent
GG moose
there's another remembrance boys
and girls
who do you think will be in the DLC I
don't know it's literally impossible to
say I have no idea it could be anything
and at this point I don't even think it
matters
vigorously beating Elden ring with my
snake
it's funny
that was good
you think about making a co-op run
I was gonna do one with metal
um but she doesn't have a PC anymore
I love that fight by the way I will
always love that fight
one year anniversary I think it gets
announced soon I don't think it will
I'd be uh surprised
88
try ascended mod
yeah I want to do I do want to try
ascended mod
I I would like to try that we did try it
once but I had it on nightmare mode and
it was kind of ridiculous like it was
pretty much impossible
I I put it on a mode that like literally
uh zero people have beaten so
we could try hell
yo what's up seventh good to see you man
how are you
I recognize that name from twitch
what up what up
that her PC vanish well it was a it was
her ex-boyfriends and now like he
obviously took the
he took the PC
so she doesn't have one now she has a
piss for
I'm gonna grab the mimic chat
and we'll vote on it later if we need it
okay
do Kratos mod Garden of eyes
he messaged me asking if I wanted to
cover his
um his new mod
and I said I don't really do videos like
that but I think bio Zio storm does
Andy didn't say anything after that so I
was like okay
I don't really do videos like that
I did make one video with metal
if you guys didn't see it it is on the
channel
and it was fun
believe me be
yeah godskin lore would be cool I think
that would go into the glomide queen
which would be sick
your glomide queen got me hooked
oh my video on her I I love that video
that's one of my favorite ones I've made
but like like I said the last
I think last stream I said this I have
to be like in the mood to make videos
like that
I have to like be inspired
and and find something like super
interesting for me to want to just like
make a lore video
or or um a cinematic questline video
something like that like I gotta be
inspired
like the the waking nightmare one
one night I was just listening to little
nightmares music OST if you guys haven't
listened to little nightmares or played
it you should
um
I was listening to that I'm like man
this go really well with this questline
made it into a whole [ __ ] video and
it I it turned out great that's
literally my favorite video I've made
but I was inspired I had to be like in
it you know
and then uh
and then I was
it's glom in time yeah we can totally
see Melina saying something like that
bro
chat can we try to get to 200 likes real
quick
200 likes
we're at 162.
let's try to get to two hundo if you
haven't liked the stream yet go ahead
and do so that'd be great thank you
sometimes you gotta remind chat
and then also I'm gonna throw this out
as a reminder if we get to 500 members
there's joy look at dude the Big Stretch
and she's gonna go plop
and she's down
I don't think you can double like if we
get to 500 members we're going to do a
double enemy double boss randomizer run
so every enemy in boss in the game will
be doubled and it will be randomized
if we get to 500 members which we're at
339 so we have a long way to go with
that but I think we can do it
who's Joy my dog right here
look at her
Joy
hi
what are you doing
uh oh
hi
she doesn't like being on camera she
immediately noticed she was on camera
and then walked over here so she
wouldn't be on camera
now I'm petting her head
a baby what are you doing
I know it's a rainy poopy day outside so
she can't go on the porch
well I guess she could
you do
you want to go on the porch
okay
can you go lay down if it's too wet then
we can't
if it's too wet then we'll have to come
back inside okay okay
it's cold as [ __ ] out there and I tried
to get her to come back inside but she
wouldn't move
she's gonna pop guys if you see her Pawn
on the door please let me know
okay let's go back to Ronnie
I'll try and listen for her
for my b-day I might become a member
demigod really
I think we have one literal God and it's
um it's bones
literal God is a hundred dollar
membership by the way
but if you guys want to become a part of
the agency
and become a tarnished it's only three
bucks
do it if you want baby
up to you we're trying to grow the
channel every day
I would like to stream full-time and
then make our streams into videos if I
can do that I'd be a happy camper ah be
a very happy camper
um we just made
members only channels in the main
Discord
I'm good Carlo how are you
sorry sorry I should have said Mommy
well I too
now do we go over here
um
yeah I tried to throw out a few uh
reminders
how do you access the Discord it is
linked in the description
everything's in the description
you download it
you do have to have a phone number
um sure our chisa can stand
if it means that to you that's what it
means
why do people come out of nowhere and
act like programless
let me just Spam out of nowhere
never seen you in the chat before and
you're spamming dog
what the [ __ ]
don't forget to leave a like everyone
take care okay have a good one Carla
have a great day at work
why was I just playing Elden ring and
turned it off because my headache then
this pops up live
um algorithm
algorithm
and giving you that kind of money
what kind of money I was seen I'm
instantly Banning you now you literally
tried to get my attention by being
annoying instaban if you prove that to
me and he just did what an idiot
idiot bro can we get L nerd in the chat
thank you
L nerd
gone
foreign
public shame
damn
shame
shame
I did that
why
oh I didn't want to re-flip it
damn it
there we go
thank you Game of Thrones reference by
the way
shame
shame
shame
he was spamming nonsense over and over
again yeah
well and then I called him out on spam
and then he said I got noticed
when you acting like that I know you
ain't a real one
you're gone
you know that basically tells me that
you're actively trying to be annoying
you out of here you do that [ __ ]
do I have to fight this guy because I
don't like doing it
I don't really think I do
oh
foreign
I can tell
Joyce secured
bigger checked by gravity
this is why we level Vigor right
exactly
gonna kill the foreskin Noble
Maybe
while still streaming I've been
streaming for two hours
it's not very long
did we get over 200 likes chat
I hope so
I clearly just needed more vigor
imagine if there was enough Vigor that
if you fell a certain distance any
distance it wouldn't kill you like if
you modded the game or something
I think it's just insta death
more
weak need more
okay that thing is a [ __ ] sniper bro
the higher your Vigor the stronger your
shins good to know
all right we did it we're gaming
bye idiot
okay I was gonna say if that reached me
I'd be a little upsetty spaghetti
what the heck I just got an email from
YouTube Hold On
they said
AGC Jake super thanks is now on shorts
introducing super thanks to shorts
it's a great way for you to connect with
fans while increasing your earnings on
shorts
when an eligible viewer purchases a
super chant a super things on your
shorts content
they'll get a colorful comment that
stands out from the rest be sure to
check out the following tips to make the
most of it
no my channel isn't getting yoinked
they're telling me that I can monetize
even more now
excellent
why do they put a cinematic here does
anybody know
other Divine tower has a cinematic
besides this one
yeah I think that's more for YouTube to
make money
at least it's not twitch tray where it's
literally a 50 50 split on anything
right
oh that's right because it's flipped
so they had to that's funny
but then now it's not
hmm
YouTube is 70 30 chat if you didn't know
so at least that's better than [ __ ]
twitch man
there's two towers and you swap between
them
it's technically still upside down no
it's not I don't know it doesn't matter
right
you all know what's happening here
stupid idiot
foreign
with a stick yesterday
it's not like
maybe that would kill him
or stagger him out of being a ball
that was my fault
I think the rolly ball he turns into is
one of the most broken things in the
game
foreign
that attack's not very cool either
that I don't know about Finn
oh this is fine
Bonnie you're a post because I think
doing that attack does more damage
[ __ ] guy
okay
there we go
yeah
we did testing plus I have enhanced
charge attacks
with my physic on
man godskin Duo is gonna be insane
did you know Melania is not the only one
that can break animations godson Noble
also can
trying to think of where he breaks
animations
nothing as obvious as Melania but I can
believe that
yeah at least we got Bernal though
hopefully we had to beat Bernal
with the wizard or we had to beat the
godskin duo without Bernal
Melania breaks animations that's funny
that's a funny comment
yeah
very much so
oh guys we need to go get more God's
great roon as well I keep forgetting
about that it's not huge but it
increases our Vigor so we might as well
foreign
did you switch staffs I mean I switched
to the
two Ronaldo's staff
which one
never mind
it's like [ __ ] all of them man
okay we got that
um
what's your favorite non-strength weapon
honestly uchigatanas double uchigatana
be my next favorite
I've never seen her break an animation
okay then I need you to go watch how
dude okay all right nope I'm not gonna
get in this argument with people I'm
just not gonna do it I'm not gonna do it
today I'm not going to
go watch the video called Melania
doesn't play fair and you will see that
she breaks animations like [ __ ] crazy
while their Poise doesn't make any sense
just everything
nope I'm not getting sucked in I'm
literally getting baited into that
conversation and I'm not doing it
I I am tired of people defending Melania
though I am over it
over it
okay I'm good I'm fine
I'm fine I'm over it
she's still fun that's not the oh that's
not the point all right
moving on go into morgot's thing
calm me down now
calm me down oh that was underground
[ __ ] I guess we could go down here
anyway
Trey you don't need to time him out for
having an opinion it's fine
bad as I think that opinion is you don't
need to get timed out for that
I also don't think that's a bad opinion
Melania can be fun if you think Melanie
is fun good for you
I think the argument that she's fair is
literally the dumbest [ __ ] I've ever
heard and I'm tired of people defending
her
tired of it
I think she's a literal meme at this
point
foreign
I'm a master
I've mastered the game to this point
mastered
[ __ ]
[ __ ] okay here we go
mastered
nope I'm not having I I want to talk
about Melania because I keep getting
baited
foreign
yeah I saw that a long time ago Russian
that was cool
I'm not going down the rabbit hole
we've had these [ __ ] discussions man
however I will say that the argument is
not that Melania isn't fun if you like
how Melania is good for you that is not
the point of the conversation and I
think that's where it just gets skewed
in a bunch of different directions and
people argue about a bunch of [ __ ] that
doesn't even make sense to the argument
but okay I'm done now
I'm done
I'm done
it must take time off my life it has to
it has to
we did do a whole stream of this
we did however that one did get deleted
Logan because it got copyright strike at
the beginning of the stream where I
played gwyn's theme from Dark Souls 1.
copyright strike for that so I just took
down the stream I'm like [ __ ] man it's
kind of weird
never expected that one to be a
copyright but it is
weird now I know
nope I will avoid dual gargoyles as much
as I possibly can Joey and I think
that's fair
that's fair
it's not a fake copywriter I even looked
it up
I guess it was like the version of the
song that I played wasn't the original
from Dark Souls or something I don't
know it was not worth it to dispute
let's say that
from softcock Game of the Year so
they're now more known hence the
copyright strike
and that was from Dark Souls 1 from
14 years ago
oh boy here we go guys
foreign
thought I'd power through that one
they did win game of the year for Sakura
big dick swinging right there
big dick swinging
oh I didn't even see those
nice
how did FIA get these guys as puppets
something to do with
god-free Godwin sorry
has to have something to do with Godwin
that was a mistake
why is this guy being so aggressive
this is not easy chat
hit one of these
go for this guy
wow they just tried to end my life
thank you
a jump attack
oh that could have been real bad
come on this fight's already annoying
enough
let me move you [ __ ] game oh my god
dude
all right here we go
Mr spams a lot
what the [ __ ] is that dude are you
kidding
foreign
foreign
spamming
Belize
I thought they'd run out I I'm God damn
skulls
don't have the Vigor anymore clearly
bro
foreign
give me the kill
God that fight is so annoying
foreign
we traded bro wow
let's go
the trade
the fight is so annoying dude
correct Jesse
that's the
the
point
I thought I bitched and moaned enough
about not getting bigger
through the entire Rune Roulette
Challenge and now we're doing only
bigger
it's pretty funny
you're damn right that counts chat
kidding me
89.
you are damn right that counts
why is fear not here
where is she
oh I still need to go back and talk to
her because she gots to kill Dee
that's right I thought I already did
that
my bad my bad dad that's my bad
okay
texting
texting currently texting
no longer texting
I think you have to beat the fire giant
I mean
perfia no
I got the dagger what is it the mop
indicate will lead you to
why how did you well I know very why
don't I good work
did you need something else no I wanted
to rest so that you could die there we
go
there we go
I need to do better than this
this will never kill God
if I stolen her now though I asked I am
okay I don't know why you keep saying
the same thing over and over again but
I'm gonna ask you to stop
and I'm gonna tell you that nobody cares
that you beat Godfrey on new game plus
six and as many times as you say it it
will make people care less
I've seen lots of people tell you to
shut up as well bro so I'm gonna tell
you a little nicer
but come on man be a part of what we're
doing here or don't
thanks
being eldenbees okay
uh
hmm
sorry thought you didn't see it yeah no
I did I yeah I did
I
did
I did okay
let's go back
oh yeah I'm good
what is it due to denial like the Dogma
you I am the guy you are an odd one
foreign thanks Sean I'm glad you like it
no borbs you don't have
it it's just there to help you in the
Twin Garg oil fight if you do give them
the armor
and die before
all right it's four to sacks time ladies
and gentlemen
brandish this day that I become I'm to
conceive brandish stay the pie becoming
yeah I think I don't think this fight
will end quick
we don't do that much damage
yeah this is a remembrance boss
as it should be
hmm
did she just move
D bossy man
let's go bossy thanks for becoming an
Elden Lord that's a big one good to have
you here
I appreciate that a lot
W's in the chat for bossy
welcome
good to have you good to have you
07.com
okay
she should be asleep now
we're gonna go goth ending because fia's
stuff has to do with vigor
I think it makes sense
she down yep all right you all know what
we're doing
no not even sound effects only music
let's go
yeah she takes Vigor but she still has
something to do with vigor
so we're gonna do her ending
I'm ready
foreign
foreign
really
dude
foreign
foreign
dodging the wrong way I think
[ __ ]
this is not going well
foreign
think so
foreign
I just got hit by [ __ ] everything bro
yes I didn't hear the I didn't hear the
beat drop I didn't hear the drop
or did I just miss it
the music says no but those attacks are
definitely yeah the music did not beat
drop
it's music wise
so awkward
foreign
sex be staggered
I don't really know
foreign
there we go
thank you
right right again thank you man
true
yeah he has to do the spinning attack
that's not stage two either
there we go
that's what we want
[ __ ]
holy [ __ ]
why are these missing
thank you
oh my God
foreign
thank you
I'm telling you guys here's what I'm
learning from this challenge bro
because we had the same thing happen
with radon
same thing happened with radon this game
is more fun
when you can't kill them super fast I am
I weird for saying that bro
like it's so much more epic and
beautiful when you're like scaled to the
level of the boss that they're at like
when we didn't just beat radon you know
super [ __ ] quick or with Ford attack
Ford attacks usually I'm like so over
leveled by this point that we don't ever
get to those moments
bro it is so cool
like all those moments that are like
perfectly
um synced with when he jumps in the air
and the music coming down like bro that
that [ __ ] is why this game was Game of
the Year and one of the best games I've
ever played right there that's so
[ __ ] cool dude
that was so awesome
kind of wish you lost more I thought I
stalled enough I thought I stalled
enough because it would just keep
looping
I tried and I tried my best there to
stall as as much as I could
we're almost fully leveled chat almost
there
that was so cool man
that was so cool
all right
we got our mending rune
uh snot
nice name
I appreciate become you becoming a great
Rune welcome good to have you here thank
you for being a member
thank you thank you
good to have you
okay what time is it what time I start
at chat 10 12 30
I'm gonna let out joy real quick guys
let's go get um Morgan's Rune or at
least go on the way there
um
I'm gonna let joy out to go pee real
quick
and then we'll be right back
uh oh she heard me
look at how good this dog is
you need to go pee
we'll go pee pee
yeah
you wanna go pee pee
yay
okay we'll be right back chat
foreign
foreign
successful p
also weird thought while I was out there
um
Elden Rings music lost to God of War
think about that
kind of weird
how I don't know
I will never
I will never let the world live that
down
ever
I will always bring that up every chance
I get
and not to say that God of War's music
is bad it's quite good
but it's not like this
It's gotta be compensation candy angel I
I agree with that it has to be
compensation candy
agreed
like did Christopher Judge deserve his
award a hundred percent
and I think in some ways to God of War
Ragnarok deserve best narrative
yes
I think it did
but you will not catch me musical score
beating Eldon ring
hell no
must have been a PR a consolation prize
by the way Elden ring won a lot of [ __ ]
that it deserved to Game of the Year for
one obviously
our best art Direction clear as day
um didn't they win game design as well
like just game design in general what
else did they win
uh best RPG
agree with that
I think Joy went to bed
yeah just game Direction
they ruined North Norse mythology I
don't I don't know about that
in our Direction yeah
exactly Russian cat
and honestly eldenreen's story compared
to
the other games not as obscure
Alvin ring took a lot of Leaps and
Bounds and strides to be more
storytelly more cut scenes more uh more
dialogue than ever before so they they
tried
but ragnarok's is just like you're
watching a movie
so
I guess it makes sense in that regard
it just in case I die here let me go
back up
I don't even think it needs it doesn't
need different storytelling drips
I don't I don't think so I I think they
endeavored perfectly into how they
wanted to tell this story which is to be
obscure
they didn't need to do more I think they
did enough
um but in comparison to Ragnarok I think
of course it's going to lose the overall
award for it
well there's one thing that I'll bring
up
chat does anybody talk about Ragnarok
anymore
not really
not that I know of
but people are still talking about Elven
ring
I'd say not really
or at least I don't see it for the two
weeks when it first came out
people liked it people you know people
were talking about it
Elden ring was like
months and months and months of like
just it broke the internet bro
I mean damn
still is in some ways
uh-oh
foreign
foreign
TV [ __ ] about God of War as well
foreign
man he is just a weird guy huh
I thought someone said that
I'm doing nothing to this guy
foreign
foreign
there we go
UTV did [ __ ] about God of War for the
first five minutes in the game
I think that like literally confirms
that he's just like he's trolling dude
like he's he's he knows his opinions are
bad but he knows that people will talk
about him because his opinions are bad
they're labeled fell Omens I guess that
means Margaret isn't the only fell omen
different than the regular enemy ones
but still
right because I I don't know if the
regular enemy ones are labeled as fell
Omens
I actually don't know because they don't
have a label when you fight them unless
they're a boss right
correct negative PR is still PR and
sorry I was running the wrong way
negative PR is still
VR right
it's weird how that works I don't really
know why people would want to
um
why people would want to grow their
themselves from negativity
but a lot of people do
can't really stop them from doing so
right I mean this is what it is
oh man I have a lot of runes
results for later
my sample is Andrew Chait I was gonna
ask you guys
do you guys think Andrew Tate is just
like a character
I don't think he is based on all these
accusations from these women that he was
like forcing to work for him
but look at that we're talking about
Andrew Tate like this is exactly what he
wants
I think his his uh
his argument in court right now is that
he's played a character but when you do
those things to women you can't claim
yourself as a character anymore right
that's just bad
bought his own hype that's crazy
and honestly like there are some things
that I've listened to with Andrew Tate
and I'm like yeah I can agree with that
but I'd say like 95 of the things he
says I'm like wow that is just [ __ ]
stupid
but there are some things where I'm like
okay sure
sure
mostly like the sedentary stuff
like uh
men and women being more sedentary and
and sitting and not working out as much
as they should I agree with that
changes the lifestyle changes the um
the mentality of the of the person when
they don't do that as much as we used to
in the past
nuggets of truth I mean I don't I do not
follow Andrew Tate I don't support
Andrew Tate in any way shape or form uh
yeah that's what I mean Trey he's
talking about like depression in men a
lot and exercise which I agree with I
think exercise
is a form of treating depression for
sure coming from someone who has been
through that
um
I think it helps a lot
I you know because I I don't know I I
was I would say in 2019 I was
clinically depressed
and then I dropped 45 pounds
don't feel that way anymore
so whether that was the exercise that
did that or just like being more
confident in my body and blah blah blah
whatever it is I can agree with that
stuff but the way he treats women and
talks about women I just don't agree
with in any way shape or form
and also I think he's facing like 15
years
or his uh sex trafficking thing
I don't think they've decided on how
long or you know it has nothing's
finalized yet but I've seen a couple
lawyers say like kind of guesstimate how
long he's looking at it's it's a long
time he's in big ass trouble
so
oh yeah he he's done a lot of harm to
young men as well
absolutely has with this um like what
billions of views on Tick Tock or
something
isn't he safe in Romania he was arrested
by a Romanian police
so I guess not
arrested Via pizza boxes
is that what happened
they were actively looking for him see I
don't know all these details and they
don't matter you know it's just like
some things of what he said made sense
in most of the things he said were just
like some of the worst things I've ever
heard so
yeah the Matrix is out to get him man
The Matrix I don't know I I watched a
whole video that went over the entire
Andrew Tate situation because
um chat brought him up a bunch of times
one day
I was like okay who is this guy and I I
looked into all of it and all I had to
hear were certain audio tapes
of things he would say about women and
two women
and I'm like yeah this guy needs to go
to prison for a long time
like he would just do
horrible things to women
so [ __ ] that guy
he boasted a vid with pizza boxes from a
pizzeria that's only in Romania while
the police were looking for him nice
what an idiot
I'll yeah I'll equip it
yeah maybe you're just not a top G right
right isn't that what he calls his
community top G's or whatever
what a goober
oh absolutely Finn absolutely
there are much better places to get
advice from than Andrew Tate
also um
I don't know how Romanian prisons are
if Andrew Tate is in an American prison
and I'm sure I'm sure this is the same
type of thing
through all prisons
but whenever other men
find out what you did to women and I
can't say the exact word on stream guys
you know you know what I'm talking about
whenever other men in prison found out
what exactly he did to women
I don't think he's gonna live
I don't care if you're a
an amazing fighter like he is if you get
jumped by five two by five guys you're
done
nobody out there is Batman
he also said clinical depression didn't
exist yeah
foreign
foreign
need that but we got it
need more Vigor from the great Rune did
I not equip it
thought I did
oh
I'm probably pissing someone off it's
Ollie
I'll get to a I'll get to a side of
Grace guys it's not a big deal
yep agreed Finn
Hey look it's Canada right exactly
um I mean I think that goes with him
Mitch
unfortunately
I think we're we're plus nine be
still trying to get a plus 10.
let's keep it going keep it moving
a lot of running in this segment
okay
mogwin
guys I don't have to do it immediately
okay
once I get Outside the Fire giant I'll
get the great root on
I also have to use a rune Arc to even
matter anyway
not a big deal
uh-oh I'm lost
now I'm not
no not yet Finn we we can get those
pretty quick whenever we get to it
I'm I'm literally still debating on even
fighting Melania
in my head
yeah
I hate her that much
and no crab we need a lobster
they've had crabs and lots of games so
they're like what's like a crab but not
a crab we're gonna still add crabs but
what's different from a crab what's like
a crab let's add a lobster X
now let's give them the ability to snipe
the player
okay excellent
foreign
guys get your panties out of a wad when
it comes to the damn [ __ ]
rate Rune activation chill
doesn't even make that big of a
difference to be honest
yep the Frozen poison swamps
when are the servers going under
maintenance I have no idea
that probably only affects pvps
they made them look like Panzer tanks
yeah they're huge
new Vari quest for ancient somber no
I'm not
foreign
thoughts on ever jail bosses they're
okay
I think they're kind of filler content
but that's fine
you kind of need that in an open world
game sometimes
I think they're interesting enough
have you lmml MLM or lmlmlm
lmlmm
elements
I don't know what you're trying to say
there Brent but thank you man
thanks
those filthy pvps pvps are fine
is there a sacred tear in that church
chat
let's go find out
I hope they announce DLC soon I wouldn't
get your hopes up about it
I've talked to Miyazaki personally in
chat
there is cool
huge
yep here's an average PVP right behind
me
foreign
foreign
foreign
Pokey
excellent
dead as hell
is rivers of blood still really good I
haven't used it in months
okay Chad here we go you ready
wow
wow
oh
yes
mmm that feels good
where the [ __ ] I am right now hello
I mean I have to go over there
rivers of blood is just okay it's really
just okay now
is this another entrance
what the flip
interesting
the taste of runes
um
I love them
well technically there's three
if that's a different entrance
technically there's three
well the other two over here are kind of
the same
you're right
I don't [ __ ] know whatever dude
there's too many things to remember in
this damn game
93
all right
chat our health bar is almost touching
you right now
it's almost touching you
It's Gonna Get You
can see that's an entrance up there so
there there is only two you're right
it's pot Boy available
Maybe
nope I don't think we've talked to
Alexander
much help is that
two thousand six hundred and eighty
eight
foreign
you guys ever seen it do that
you see that they like hovered around me
I love this fight Chad it's so great
such a great fight
look at that beautiful
would you take Melania over fire Giant
no
I I dislike Melania more than the fire
Giant
Melania is easier than the Eldon Beast
okay you must have had a Faith Build or
something
this cutscenes incredible I'll say
there's a lot of good things about the
fire giant I just think it's like just
not
well designed especially phase two
but it's okay
uh
-huh
I'm not gonna talk
do a thing
thank you
damn
jump me jump me jump me yeah yeah
no
foreign
I just tried to stab him three times and
it just didn't do anything
hello
foreign
God damn Chad
foreign
he just tried to [ __ ] me so hard and
that that right there is why I hate this
[ __ ]
yep
this [ __ ] guy man
first try
first try by the way
and Finn gifting a membership let's go
chat that's four memberships on the day
out of 50. let's get it
I'm kidding
Ben thank you very much I appreciate
that thank you
w w
let's go I'm gonna have to lower that
goal it's too much
foreign it's too much all right
very nice
let us continue
let us
continue
is that it oh we can get one more level
chat
one more
you might be able to survive malakat's
AOE now I think we could
how much health
two thousand seven hundred and twelve
mm-hmm
two thousand
seven hundred and twelve
you have the Vigor of a limb grave boss
almost died
still not out of the woods there we go
excellent
are you over on Vigor from your
talismans
no
I don't think there's any Talisman that
just increases the attribute of your
Vigor without affecting other attributes
as well
it just affects the overall Vigor that
you have not the attribute
okay
melanoton
can't use radagon Source seal it
upgrades other things besides Vigor this
world is in dire need of repair
and death
indiscriminate
are you prepared so dark and cold today
chat a cardinal sin
very well
let my hand rest upon you
dude Daniel I am fully in the realm that
like Nicola and so much of the story is
actually based on berserk
okay chat where's our tree favor plus
two
see all shut up and I can just put it on
I gotta pee real quick
BRB
oh a tree you shall burn
for the sake of the new Lord
yeah we're doing age of dustborn
did you wash your hands why would I do
that I got a clean dick
the classic rocks alongside
shall one day meet the road of destined
death
sometimes I wish they would stop
speaking in riddles goodbye
the literal God
don't forget to wipe what my pee hole
uh all right let's go
we can level up one more time Chad
but where's Earth tree Faber plus two
again
didn't you guys say that was after
malacath
which we are not at yet
was more got difficult we first tried
them
literal first try
Ashen capital
so yeah I can't go there until I beat
malikath right
foreign
we're doing fia's ending
we already got moogs we already have
plus one or a tree's favor
what berserk references are in Elden
ring
really dude
that's funny
all I gotta say is think of mikola and
then think of Griffith
I'd say that's the main one
foreign
yes V is ending
Griffith was a butterfly
where did you get that
actually
wow damn reason I got to run and have
some money
with the 20 Super Chat thank you man
holy [ __ ]
that's a big one
have a great day I appreciate you giving
me some money
before that thank you man I really
appreciate that thank you thank you
thank you
via dies no matter what Russian
all right first try no Bernal let's
watch it happen it's gonna be sick
we need Bernal
thank you again reefs
that's big
thank you
would you have liked to have gotten
we have so much health
but not that much
foreign
sucks
come here
foreign
said they translated the lyrics and it
turned out to just not be true
which kind of sucks
damn they're just trying to clap me
right there
foreign
that was risky but we got to get risky
for the whiskey sometimes
input reading
foreign
thought I was out of range whatever
all right no more heels
foreign
my game's lagging a lot
foreign
this sucks
I'm lucky
low endurance for this fight sucks man
now we're gonna use Bernal that was just
because that was my first attempt
that was so good though wasn't it holy
[ __ ]
that was so good
I'm just gonna get Bernal right here
I don't think they're guarding Malachi
Peter
I think they're here to stop us but
not for that reason
been having lunch
classes I've been calling him today
Vigor Mortensen
I like it Andrews
thank you man I appreciate the five
thank you very much
it's so dark in this oh God uh
fine
somewhat
I assume they just want us dead
that's why they're here
that's why they've been tracking us the
entire game you know what I mean
why is Bernal over here
what attack did I just do
oh God
heavy running poke I don't think I've
done that yet
that was kind of fun
foreign
I got greedy
no I couldn't see nice
thank you
big swing
no Bruno no
I don't think he could heal man
I think we're okay
God I hate the delay on these attacks
bro I hate them
diamonds
Bernal was not the best there Chad kinda
weird
foreign
really
that would have been bad
why is he rolling the
he rolled the opposite direction he
always does what the [ __ ]
God I hate fighting the skinny one
really
I I mean what the [ __ ] dude you just did
it
foreign
they're trying to [ __ ] me you can feel
it
look at this gamer movement right here
foreign
way too risky man that was my fault
damn chat
that time he delayed it when he hit he
hit me and killed me there it was
instantaneous
Bernal dying there sucked bro
500 members and we have dual boss
randomize around let's get the
memberships up that's what I'm saying
Peter Wednesdays tend to be uh pretty
slow
how many likes we had
Wednesdays are always the slowest day no
matter what like uploading a normal
video doing a live stream
people don't go on the internet as much
on Wednesdays
only I have one more flask I guess I
could have another one
there he is I was like where's the other
one
he's fighting outside isn't he you gotta
love it man
you gotta love it
you gotta love when Bernal fights the
[ __ ] Knights outside
Bernal right there right in your face
there you go
okay
big
ger
there we go
I'll never understand the belly flop
foreign
okay Bernal is going god mode right now
can we get some W's in the chat for
Bernal God damn bro
oh my God he is literally soloing them
for me
holy moly
and W's in the chat for Andreas thank
you man thank you for becoming a great
room good to have you here appreciate it
dude
our membership goal is looking low today
but that's okay
every membership helps
I tanked it
foreign
holy [ __ ] Bernal
wow
it was the warm-up with the Knights that
did it
wow
more
you'll never understand it chat never
will
wow
we both had the same idea
nice
Bernal said I'm done [ __ ] around boys
I'm done [ __ ] around
and there's our last level guys
our last level that we can even get
99 vigor
how we looking oh wait let me do this
real quick
so the the health can't reach you Chet
it tries
but not quite
that's as high as our Vigor can go
well I guess we could do
some other stuff
we have Buffs
they want to touch the health it's right
there man it's trying
I must go even further Beyond
okay so where her tree favor plus two is
after we beat malkath what about Crimson
tier
is that a thing
this is the Crimson Hood increase your
health
yeah I just popped a tray
it does
do I just get that from the shack
where uh Roderick is
right over here Yonder
there's a physic tier that increases Max
health
just overall okay
foreign
that's a seed I thought you'd get her
clothes here
where do you get her clothes chat
you get it Stormville near the grafted
Scion oh [ __ ] okay I didn't know that
um
I don't already have the Crimson Hood
no way I don't remember putting it on
nope don't have it
I don't know why that was said
it gives one Vigor hey
it increases the Vigor we get it
because we're about to fight malacath
we're gonna need everything we can get
everything
oh scum nut okay
I'm not scum nut man
where is it again
right here
no
Vigor is Max but we're using other means
oh this one's on the pile of bodies
really
I thought that was something else
yeah I know what you're talking about
now
why is he still looking here
I
don't
know
I knew it
unless I
yeah I knew that wasn't where that was
first that then the momento
so what do I do that and it'll be there
really
you need to talk to roderica and come
back
foreign
foreign
thought I just died what the [ __ ]
I mean she already took off her Hood
chat
so
I swear I have not gotten the hood this
way
yeah
maybe I gotta do more
like more of a quest line or whatever
God she already took off her [ __ ]
Hood man I thought it'd just be there
I swear I've gotten the hug and the hood
not doing this
it's not there it's at the shack
let me do this sure
why are you still making weapons
my looks
I wonder why I can't give her the
Memento well
never mind that's her thing
thing I see
is it this like too late
is there
yes he is a must begotten
I see I I think you guys just say [ __ ]
instead of actually knowing
I think you just say [ __ ] sometimes
I see
you need to stop asking sometimes
can't really do anything else
okay it won't give us a hundred vigor
you did her Quest wrong
we didn't know about this till now
all right I'm over it okay
malakith
just look it up you're at your own damn
PC okay dude I love how chat just
switches up sometimes holy [ __ ] it's so
weird
foreign
oh my God
oh please [ __ ]
I rolled into his face and got hit
foreign
foreign
there we go
nice
yeah it's in the effects Wiki
so why why don't I just not stream them
hmm
I can just do that
instead of asking chat
I know memories are kind of hazy though
some people think it's one way and then
it is another way or it can be done in
multiple different ways
and they're not aware of the multiple
different ways
but telling me to just get on the wiki
go ahead and [ __ ] off
ow
foreign
want to take a ride with me to have a
sleepover
and take a tour with this too sure
you think they're bugged angel I don't
know about bugs there's just like
multiple things
no my sister's texting me
about something else
I wish it was the couch
I just tried to level
Rodriguez questline must be completed
and spirit tuning must be unlocked for
this item to appear
got it
no my sister is not single
here we go
foreign
foreign
foreign
sometimes the hitbox on that attack is
[ __ ] insane
same with a lot of attacks honestly
foreign
thank you
I'm sorry but what do you think Vigor
only it bigger only means
had to be said
just think for a second
think for two seconds and you'll get it
holy [ __ ]
why does Chad get weird when the
afternoon hits
all morning it was great and then
afternoon hits and it's like just it
just instantly gets weird I don't get it
did you get home from school
brought your brain there can't think for
yourself anymore okay
remember three hours ago when I said I
was gonna be nice to chat
oh it's hard
it's hard sometimes
all right
too far away
agreed
[ __ ] range on that attack dude
foreign
good at dodging that one not right now
he's staggered me oh we're gonna get
away with it
I am gaming currently
foreign
holy gaming happening holy [ __ ] chat
ah and a rage on that
the [ __ ] range on that bro damn
okay honestly I zoned out after I yelled
at the kid in chat what happened
I'm also sorry for yelling at you chat
that was really good though I'm getting
so good against malachath
I'm getting so good against malachets
though bro
use a faster weapon
which one would that be
when I can't level anything but Vigor
what weapon what weapon is that that we
can fully upgrade and and do more damage
than the never mind
because I'm sure there's some
foreign
Jake yells at someone asking an honest
question and wonders why his streaming
numbers aren't higher
you have to be baiting there's no
[ __ ] way you're serious
foreign
oh God
here
foreign
I'll take it though
knew it I [ __ ] knew it
big hits
oh
clean
I got baited there kinda okay
foreign
foreign
I'm getting kind of [ __ ] right now
it was going so well
and then I spoke
what's new all right let's get it
what the [ __ ]
holy [ __ ]
all right here we go
why am I crouched God damn it dude
oh my God I
I pressed down on my [ __ ] stick too
far
oh my God I was killing it and then I
just got hit by everything dude
pain
guys we can clearly kill him why are you
all telling me to do something different
I literally just didn't dodge correctly
is that what you guys do in your
playthroughs like when you died you just
instantly go in like Farm other [ __ ]
change your weapon
yes makes sense
maybe do that in your playthrough
foreign
to see people getting timed out like
crazy I don't know what's happening
okay if all the young kids are getting
back from school why are they like the
most weird people
what the [ __ ]
like I know they're kids but like God
damn shut the [ __ ] up
it's like every stream at this point
that's not being a kid wouldn't a kid
just say l nerd you're bad
have that then these [ __ ]
Shins
like I've said for weeks
nice
I when I think of kids I think of like
they just like oh I'll make a little bad
that seems fine
that would be that would be fine instead
it's just like do this do that shut the
[ __ ] up
I don't want your suggestion so just
don't do it I don't know how many times
I can say it uh
every stream
weird
okay I don't know what that was in
Discord I did not get a message
foreign
foreign
oh
he's gonna do the thing
how do you get rid of that or dodge it
don't matter
one more hit chat
try to end it
nice
good stuff
holy [ __ ] how did you do that without a
mimic tear holy [ __ ] how'd you do that
without urge seal plus two
whatever the [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] Jake how'd you do that
without Frost pots
holy [ __ ] Jake how'd you do that without
Blasphemous claw
holy [ __ ]
sorry dude
I'm sorry at this point of death is
Unbound
I I got you bungalus
I got you bro
I'm not losing my mind I just think some
people in chat are stupid
yeah I've heard of night comment Dylan
yeah I have
a planet how'd you do that with such low
vigor
you definitely needed to allocate that
flash Jake
farewell it is then
it's really not a lot of the Lord yet
we're all timed out right now
you really should tune out these guys
I'm not really mad okay
it's all for entertainment
everything you're seeing on screen is
fake
I'm not real I am I'm not even a human
I'm an AI
foreign
I can set my programming to where I can
only do what you say shut up people Jake
legendary gamer
thanks angel
I appreciate both those super chats man
thank you
the self is a construct can you go back
to Reddit or something
all these people I'm not even talking to
you Ezekiel sorry just like all these
people go back to Reddit I'm sorry you
just got back from school and you got a
72 on your math test which means you now
have to take the final I'm sorry that
you had a bad day
but don't take it out on me as a
streamer just don't do it
now try to level up Vigor to resist
in-game bosses more
now try to level up Vigor to resist
in-game bosses more I don't even know
what that means
excuse me mod but what is the problem
here you can't chill out on some comment
be the bigger men peace out you have to
be chronically on Reddit if you think
that
you have to be chronically on Reddit I
can't
see a normal person speaking words like
this I just can't
that's true silly and I did go get it
and use it and it was fine it was good
if you're getting timed out it means
you're saying [ __ ] that we don't want in
the chat
it's not hard to understand
it's not my moderator's fault for timing
you out it's your fault for saying
something we don't like do not blame my
moderators or we will just permaban you
know they're doing a great job
foreign
your Vigor against him does not matter
he will kill you instantly
I won't support you if you permaban
someone for his opinion online
what happened to what's going on what
happened bro
I will get off immediately if this is
going to continue
what are you all talking about
Christ
God damn
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you guys
you're like the biggest bunch of [ __ ]
I've ever seen
you weren't joking
oh my God bro you were not joking
way to throw that out there after I
caught it in the chat that time
holy [ __ ]
it's like after 1 pm
at least my time
this gets weird
where do all these like djinns come out
of [ __ ] nowhere
foreign
look at that damage
wow
you thought well until now
he might have the most damage of any
boss in the game
no like at this I think he scales his
damage to how much Vigor you have
and it doesn't mean anything
no I haven't killed Moog
we killed little Moog
hate the attack
up almost died
really
right oh and okay oh we're gonna double
that up
foreign
buffed in
general a long time ago I don't know
about the latest patch though
but he's been buffed for a long time
and he can heal
right
foreign
yeah if you have the ruins great sword
and you spam it over and over again he
literally can't move
we're just gonna throw those out twice
man
foreign
foreign
foreign
I have to heal because that [ __ ] can
just one shot me
foreign
wow
wow
[ __ ] glitched up
that one hurt man
Jesus
he must have the most damage output in
the game
come on bro let's do this
there ain't no way you got five of those
dog
thank you
yo thank you Peter we got it man we got
it
we'll get it
bro you're still stuck we've been here
for like 10 minutes what do you mean
still stuck
go do your homework little bro
foreign
thank you for the three months man
I appreciate it dude
thank you dude
I need to make an alert for
re-memberships I think that's why it
doesn't come up sometimes
but thank you dude
yeah apparently that guy has not fought
Gideon buffed
it's probably the best weapon to use
against him trick
foreign
this [ __ ]
huh
three
two
wow
I think I'm dead oh I got caught
wow dude
I know our build is only vigor
but I feel like this is a little
ridiculous right
I feel like this is a little bit
too much
to a point where it's like kind of
ridiculous
foreign
you know considering I don't I have 99
health and I'm getting basically two
shot
yeah everything's easier with the mimic
man of course
lack of stamina on the enemy
like they don't have their own stamina
bar
right
foreign
these rings are insane
foreign
dude no [ __ ] dude
I had to dodge this I don't like what do
you want me to do there
I didn't mean to go for two attacks
foreign
that's crazy how much damage that thing
does
all right here we go
now he's holding them down
just run out please
what
what
hello
you thought well until now
I mean he definitely he does not have an
FP bar there's no way but sometimes I'll
see him go like this with his staff and
I'm like well that means he ran out of
FB but I don't see him filling up a
flask
foreign
that still hit me
I thought well until now
that's his heel no I'll see him do it
with the flat with his staff not go like
this that's a different animation he'll
lift it up try to drink it and go like
this
I'll see him do this with his staff
instead that's a totally different
animation I don't know what he's doing
it for maybe he does run out of stamina
at that point
I don't know
sure that missed I guess
oh well until now
it's from having no stamina
his stamina bar must go three times
across the screen
but I guess he does run out at some
point
man
he tries to use an incant on his staff
that's a possibility
does he switch
thank you
what where is it hitting me
foreign
that attack in particular of course
foreign
foreign
wow you thought well until now
it's insane
we use the club all the way up to
getting the serpent Hunter
I mean I know I know our build is stupid
like we only have Vigor and nothing else
but this is insane
thank you
I can't jump out of it
that still hit me
so I don't get it
foreign
what do I do in that situation
you die that's what I do
foreign
I will cheese you till the ends of the
Earth
as you do me
I I mean what what the [ __ ] wow
this fight's completely [ __ ] broken
that's where I'm at this fight's broke
it
I guess if you had a normal build you
would kind of just roll through them
there when I got him in a stun lock but
like dude
this is insane
look at look at them stop right there to
hit me
okay
what did Brent say
I missed it I almost want to restart
yeah
you thought well until now
raw spots of course
got it frost pots yay
I was trying to cheese them and then he
did the [ __ ] god skin [ __ ] that I
have to roll out of
foreign
how did that Miss
okay okay okay you thought well until
now
foreign
let's see if that makes a giant
difference
let's just see
I haven't leveled to plus 10 yet
let's see if that makes a giant
difference it could I guess probably not
that much
yeah I just need twice the stamina
but I can't oh no
Morning Star Hammer does that have
requirements to use
you tried leveling IQ okay buddy
it's real funny
you think Gideon scales because he's
all-knowing
I don't know how that would affect his
vigor
or his damage output
what are the requirements because I
can't increase my attributes besides
vigor
no Mira
not yet
all-knowing would affect his mind which
makes sense
I don't know if there's a lore reason
chat why he can literally do a thousand
damage per hit
12 strength eight decks then I can't do
it I can't increase my strength
foreign
s are the biggest issue to be honest
foreign
foreign
three [ __ ] times
foreign
I wasn't looking damn it
foreign
not even you
a man
cannot kill
oh God
dude [ __ ] that guy oh my God
also [ __ ] the guy who said
still stuck on him
oh my God
you clearly haven't played Elden ring
since it [ __ ] released
I don't know if the plus one made a
difference maybe a bit
but uh
I think we just kind of did the Pokey
pokes
the Pokey pokes there
made a difference
why are you a dick all the time
foreign
where did that come from
how am I the dick
holy [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is wrong with
some people dude
I don't understand
celebrate GG thank you Brian I
appreciate it
thank you dude
foreign
I mean am I even being a dick chat
foreign
stamina
foreign
you can be at times but rare I'm I'm
wondering where I'm a dick though I'm
serious
that will be the only time I'm a dick to
somebody in chat if the is if they're
being a dick to me good service how does
that make me a dick
I don't understand
I literally just don't understand
foreign
foreign
foreign
damn combos
I'm being baited out I don't know
okay I'm disbanding this guy obviously
Jesus Christ what I I literally just
I don't get a chat I I do not like being
called an [ __ ] when I feel like I'm
not being an [ __ ] and try hard not to
be an [ __ ]
I'm
I don't know that I'm upset about it I
guess
not a real big fan of being told
something that I don't think I am
foreign
actually hit me there
foreign
I thought he'd go back damn it
oh
sometimes chat makes you angry I'm
yeah I
how am I the [ __ ]
or being baited by people
who are trying to get a rise out of me
in my own live stream
foreign
it was I didn't mean to do a heavy
attack
there'll always be trolls yeah
okay sorry I'll just I don't know I
don't know what to do at this point
I literally have no idea what to do at
this point
makes me just not want to talk
thank you
foreign
foreign
there we go
I have no idea silly I have I honestly
haven't been looking at Chad
foreign
I definitely rolled okay
foreign
okay
not great
I learned where all his kids got their
Delay from okay dude
give me a minute man
can't heal twice if he does that
foreign
when the [ __ ] do I attack him
sometimes he doesn't do that one
damn
there's like no opportunity unless he
does the giant big roaring stomp that's
when I can hit him for a piss ton
otherwise nothing
also the movers gave me a link to track
their truck which is kind of cool
so they're on their way not to here
but uh to where the couch is
you'd only do light I can't even do
heavy attacks
on the on the jumps
it's being kind of weird okay
didn't have the stamina
together
hope this helps a little bit
no you're good Ethan thank you man
I need to get better at dealing with
them
that's what I'm realizing
I don't really know what to do about it
but thank you man
foreign
oh I forget that the [ __ ] ax can hit
me too
foreign
foreign
it's silly not get a reason why you got
banned
timed out he didn't even get banned like
why is he pissing and moaning still
thank you
so it's got to be like the first time
he's ever been timed out and he's still
mad
that was my fault
dude horror lives hard as [ __ ] man
the silly Silly's been in the chat for
like months so what's what's going on
with silly
I have no I I even answered I don't know
why you got timed out but you need to
calm down about it could Jesus Christ
he didn't like it
yeah I know GB I'm trying it's
easier said than done
what do you get banned
all right
getting timed out for five minutes is
not a big deal
foreign
it's not a big deal in any way shape or
form it just you got timed out sorry
I think one of us misunderstood
something he said
uh kind of weird he said that's all and
then he got timed out okay
okay
and he's mad enough to say that we're in
a kindergarten class
what
this is what I'm talking about bro
foreign
oh Jacob
dang dude thank you
13.37 the joys tweet fund thank you man
I really appreciate that
okay thank you
very kind
she's asleep in the bedroom right now
that was my bad
oh no I should have died
huh
sometimes the hitboxes in this game bro
sometimes man
I thought I could get two in there
I got into an actual argument with
fighting Cowboy once but he got but you
gotta let that [ __ ] go I still enjoy his
content and see eye to eye and see eye
to eye like oh [ __ ] nowadays
that will be yeah honestly most of the
things that like I yell at somebody and
chat about I forget like
immediately after
today's been so much that it's hard to
not
I don't know what's going on with people
today
it's definitely a very odd day
that kick is so hard to read
damn that comes out fast
what
I can't believe that hit me dude what
the [ __ ]
I can't believe that hit me bro
foreign
I thought I dodged I guess not
okay I want to beat this guy and then we
we go again tomorrow because the the
couch is coming guys well
yeah it's still not even at my parents
yet
so we got a lot of time they have to
move it load it
and then drive here
so we got time but I want to clear out
the living room before they get here
obviously
now I'm doing good we just gotta like
not
not [ __ ] up
like that
like that
okay I want to go again that was this
bad stock Bros how's this an awful start
okay Banning that guy immediately just
don't time people out that say dumb [ __ ]
like that just immediately ban them
it's [ __ ] weird
yeah totally a couch stream right you
guys would like that
well it'll be in the background starting
tomorrow
yeah it didn't count didn't count that
was as bad
didn't like that attempt
we're doing good though we can clearly
beat him
I'm getting greedy
don't worry about what Mike said
he got banned for a reason
foreign
foreign
what do you guys think Godfrey benches
elephants
I am usually so [ __ ] good at dodging
that and I've just been terrible
a small aircraft carrier yeah I
literally can't reach out I guess damn
stage two greed oh God
Creed no
no
that is so below 50 percent
that is so below 50 man
did my doggy come out
we have to go again tomorrow chat
Jojo
she might be dead ass asleep
hmm
the lion is his gym he is constantly
squat walking a [ __ ] Lion on his back
that's a good point
well half a line
foreign
with this much bigger I want to be
greedy but I can't
go
sometimes the attempts don't go very
well boys
where you at
and she's done she's done for today
he's probably getting hungry
pretty much Angel yeah
I would say guys getting to 99 bigger is
completely pointless
in the end game
because if you're gonna get hit you're
gonna get hit by a lot for a lot
now we're just doing bad damage
foreign
of course
uh that was weird
foreign
I jumped into his [ __ ] foot
pain and suffering
foreign
wow that was bad
that was really bad
come on man I know I had stamina too
dude why does that happen I like
accidentally pressed to when I'm trying
to go backwards
when I'm trying to run away backwards
sometimes I press too hard down on my
stick and I crouch and there's so much
animation on the screen that I can't see
my character dude
so I can't tell he's crowds yet
dang it
all right I got one or two more good
attempts in me and then I gotta stop
because they're they're about to get
there
this is a plus 10 weapon
he got scared he did dude you actually
did
foreign
oh my God these attack combos are so
rare
that one in particular
now he's doing them constantly
thank you
huh
foreign
did someone ask why I'm using why I'm
not using pots
dude I'm not kidding at this point I'm
just like actively
I'm actively just not [ __ ] gonna use
it because
it's just a meme in this stream now like
unless we're doing a pot only run
somehow I'm just not gonna use it
maybe that's what makes me an [ __ ]
maybe that's it that's like my uh
my toxic trait
huh
wow he went across field with that one
was that rare ass combo
I [ __ ] up my stagger if I had
getting hit that one time
have a good one Brian
foreign
foreign
foreign
oh my God
I can't move
I'm gonna call that unlucky
foreign
foreign
that [ __ ] attack man holy [ __ ]
foreign
it's so hard to see
oh
foreign
that combo is [ __ ] insane
that combo was [ __ ] crazy
oh man
oh this in-game is gonna suck
I want to do it guys but I don't have
time I literally don't have time I have
to stop
I'm sorry
I'm sorry guys
I actually have to stop I don't have
time I have to walk joy and clean out
the living room before they get here
and they just got there so I'm sorry
we're gonna have to go again tomorrow
dang it dude
I thought that was it too well we can
clearly do it but man
it's still tough all right
movie Trucks here yep I'm inning stream
now Mom
good to know all right
guys
I know it says starting soon but
it's the outro
have a great rest of your night great
rest of your day
um I'm gonna try I don't know how I'm
gonna do it but I'm gonna have to try
and figure out how to have these baiters
does not [ __ ] like [ __ ] with my head
I don't know what it is man
I don't know what it is
there's just some things that are said
in chat that just confuse the living
[ __ ] out of me and I I guess I should
just ignore it I don't know
I don't know man I've been streaming for
years
on a last year or so on YouTube or so
years on Twitch
I haven't really had this issue before
so it's not like I'm not
experienced in how it works it's just
weird it's it's more strange on YouTube
I don't know how to put it man
anyway
just ban I don't want to just ban people
though I don't want to do that I don't
want to just literally ban everyone who
says something that we think
is wrong or whatever I don't know
unless it's just like blatantly like
racist or what whatever like someone
earlier
now we don't need to flood chat with
positive thoughts it's you know I I
guess I should just be it I guess I have
to get used to YouTube although I've
been streaming for
a year on YouTube
and I've never been bothered by chat
this much
then the last few days so I don't know
what's up with that
I don't know what's going on
yeah maybe they're new I don't know we
we get new people in here all the time
so I'm I'm not sure
but we'll be back tomorrow with the
couch so that's cool
hopefully with the couch
it's not you uh anyone in particular
the penalty for reaching 100k
I guess so less viewers on stream and
more subscribers somehow also Ezekiel
thank you for the for the membership man
I really appreciate that thank you thank
you
yep couch High metal I'm about to get
off sorry
um but I'm gonna go walk joy and I'm
gonna feed her and everything and then
we're gonna get everything ready so
guys have a great rest of your day
and I will see you tomorrow around the
same time okay
okay middle all right
um
yeah I don't want to just ban people
we'll figure it out man we'll we'll
figure it out bro
anyway have a great rest of your day and
I'll see you guys tomorrow
bye bye